après deux mois de séparation forcée
jean françois rochon s'apprête à revoir
sa mère par la surpêche c'est possible
pour les deux pour le chc le deal
l'accueil des proches aidants est source
de stress supplémentaire ya un risque
ans et c'est sûr mais jean-françois doit
donc signer un formulaire dans lequel il
reconnaît les risques de la visite il
enfile un masque chirurgical une blouse
réglementaire et même une visière aucun
risque à prendre
sa mère monique papineau-couture vie
dans une aile qui est infecté
une timide poignée de main qu'on tente
de prolonger
c'est le seul signe d'affection qui est
autorisée jusqu'à ton est donné au moins
de précieux moments surtout que la dame
de 88 ans a été infecté par l'aco vide
mais vient d'apprendre qu'elle est
guérie
trois heures plus tard jean-françois
ressort après être passés en zones de
désinfection c'est un moment que je
n'oublierai jamais il pense avoir
contribué à sa convalescence
ma mère a mangé plus aujourd'hui que
majorité du temps c'est une grosse
différence avoir quelqu'un garde
l'amorcé seul un avantage aux yeux de la
direction qui veut tout de même éviter
que les aidants naturels deviennent des
vecteurs de contagion s'ils reviennent
régulièrement chaque jour on leur
demande de ne pas trop se promener en
ville donc pour faire les courses
idéalement pas de transports en commun
jean françois rochon soit revenir
souvent
même s'il est épaté par le travail du
personnel des remercier pour ce qu'ils
ont fait pour ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui
pour ce qui continue de faire c'est pas
fini ici david gêne-t-il et radio canada
montréal